now that you're a mama do you see a
little bit of a helicopter in you or are
you saying that will never ever be me of
course the urge to stop anything from
ever hurting or negatively affecting
your baby you know yeah do you have a
parenting model that you follow
um
John and Kate Plus Eight
IES
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was kind of the it's one of the
incredible things about doing this with
you is seeing just how much of a
priority being a mother is for you and
how deeply you care about that over
everything else it was it was Brian
Tyree Henry told me everything by the
way he says call him Uncle Brian
[Laughter]
oh that's very good I mean it's only
been a year it could be give me 18. look
at this need a car date our son this
summer and bring him out of his shell
before College in exchange we'll give
you a Buick Regal so what about this and
like pushing the envelope in a comedy
made you say yeah okay I'm in I mean I
think it is as funny as it is because
it's really pushing the envelope and
really inappropriate and raunchy and you
know I've known Gene for years and he's
the funniest person I've ever met in my
life so when I read it I mean I was just
I was dying and when you're on set like
making something like this
you're like it's it's hilarious the more
the closer you're getting to like the
line and the more you're kind of Dancing
with the line but of course after you
wrap something you're like that you're
like are we gonna be okay
that was kind of my next question was
there ever time where it was like okay
this is really funny but can we do this
God I there probably should have been
somebody like that on set
but there wasn't
I think it was always like it was never
like can we do this or like will people
be mad at us but more like
are we like allowed to do this like well
like or like you know like parents get
mad at us you know like I feel like it
was more like we were just like kids
laughing was it Jennifer Lawrence that
got the yes from you or did you read the
script it's funny I I always read a
script before I do the tape but when I
did this first self tape I didn't have
time to read the script and uh then
after doing that I read the script and I
was so thankful because if I read it
before I would have been freaking out
about the pressure I was like this is
the funniest script ever I have to play
this role um obviously yes the chance to
work with Jen is like a huge one I don't
know why you wanted to start with that
I gave you gave you yeah yeah I know you
did you did
right and it was I would say a massive
part of wanting to do it huge um huge in
fact you know like if only if the movie
was less good it would be 100 of why but
the movie also happens to be so
extremely funny and um and I I just
connected to this character so
immediately um Jennifer I read that you
likened acting with Andrew in kind of
the same vein as Christian Bale he's
like he's shaking his head like what the
hell the reason the reason that I make
that connection in my mind was because
the most improv I had ever done I think
with somebody was with Christian Bale
and an American Hustle at that point I
was like 20 great and I remember feeling
like
we were both really like running like we
could like you know and I and I was
really proud of myself for keeping up
being feeling like I was keeping up with
Christian Bale and so when I say it's
the exact same as acting with with
Christian Bale there was just nowhere
that I could go or that we could go or
that Gene could throw at us that Andrew
couldn't just pick up and just you know
make a touchdown with it that's a pop
your collar moment it's a pretty insane
thing to hear her say really true
so on the flip side what was your
experience then you know working and
acting with you yeah beat that yeah
mostly I mean mostly negative
no like like me like if it was
kind of wild how normal it felt we would
laugh between takes during takes and
like the board games we play in between
shots what were the board games we
played a lot of this game called super
fight super fight it was a big one yeah
which is basically just like you make
like a fighter that'll be like Willy
Wonka with a you know you draw the robot
arm you draw cards versus like Mr and
there were times that we were he would
be like in a what is called a um
I guess you'll just bleep this
like like doing like nude scenes just
like I am a paper bag
I mean the whole game is you just argue
about who would win in a fight and
that's the whole game the fact that you
played it like in your banana hammock is
the banana banana I think it's good we
can go skinny dipping what about sharks
run here
do have to just strip it all down I was
like nervous about having a 20 year old
co-star just because I was like that
sounds
annoying but they just like annoy me all
day and so that was just like a huge
relief like minute one I was like oh
you're cool okay how did you have
because you both did you know
do you prepare for that how do you get
in your head for that or do you even
have to
I don't know it didn't really feel like
a big deal to me I just yeah you just
kind of
just kind of do it yeah everybody was so
so considerate we had intimacy
coordinators we had a ton the set was
closed like it was a safe and
professional as it could possibly be
while the two of us were still able to
like make light a bit and like yeah joke
around about what a kind of ridiculous
situation that we were in the thing we
all love about Jen in this business is
that you kind of are the ultimate cool
girl like you're just fun you just yes
seriously it's like what you see is what
you get and I didn't love that more than
when I saw you at can and you were
snatched from head to toe and then had
your flip-flops on okay I love you thank
you for bringing this up I would really
like to straighten this out I was not
making a political statement not that
like I wouldn't like I totally agree
with I have no idea until it like came
out and they that there was like a whole
controversy with people wearing flats or
like walking on the red carpet Barefoot
or so I had no clue my shoes were a size
too big and I knew I wore them I wore
heels going up but then I forgot to take
a picture with my production team
excellent cadaver so we had to take an
excellent cadaver picture and I knew I
would eat if I went down in the shoes
that were size too big I put on the
flip-flops and then you know everybody's
like whatever what a statement wow I'm
all for making a statement I just would
want it to be like on purpose I didn't
want to take credit for and see I just
thought Jennifer she's just like us like
she couldn't wear those shoes it's true
though you are so she's just like her
feet bloat When She Flies
but I like I wore compression socks you
find yourself in those situations
because you are so unapologetically like
yourself
you really are just like us if your feet
blow when you fly yes the whole I'd walk
out and I'm like what happened and then
you're chugging water chugging water
chugging water because you're like I'm
so bloated from the flight and then you
put your shoes on the next day and
they're all full size too big we just
hit a milestone anniversary last year uh
10 years since the Hunger Games
I'm fine wow
you're so old
no I remember shooting the first one and
like I was 21 and we were like waiting
to do it and I thought about this moment
I was like it's so crazy that like one
day I'll be like an old lady and these
films will be 10 years old I thought
about it like specifically 10 years so
I'm gonna need you to stop saying old
lady like you imagine doing a two shot
with this new bile Angelic
I've steered pretty far away from ever
saying how old I was when the hundreds I
don't say the number were you numbers
were you ten I was born
I was probably 10 yeah oh my God
oh if it was 10 years ago last year I
mean you're so cute and so nice I can't
be mad but that's really great It's
upsetting but you still want to like
punch a hole yeah right yeah yeah we've
got a prequel on the horizon I'm looking
forward I'm very much looking forward to
it I mean it's all the same gang so I
get pictures from like the crew and um
and it just seems It's really exciting
I'm very excited to see it we've seen
you done everything now so what genre is
next now that you've tackled this one
I mean my favorite genre to watch is
horror I mean but my fear of doing a
horror movie is that it would like break
the fourth wall for me and then like
maybe I wouldn't be scared anymore whoa
you know yeah preserving the theater it
would be like if I did reality TV and
I'm like wait a minute this was written
yeah like what if I was like unband or
pump rules I want to be
watch no no I'm not caught up
here
[Music]